this is the mutual fund Factory where
all the worlds mutual funds are produced
fund elves wraps Stardust lemon drops
and a nickel in a unicorn bladder which
is then delivered via dragon sled to
brokerage firms who sell them to
customers the customer buries the mutual
fund in their backyard and after 30 or
40 years money tree starts blossoming
just in time for retirement babe that's
not remotely true I know but we have to
get people excited about mutual funds
somehow they're an important option and
saving for retirement and most people
don't even know what they are even some
people who own them like in their 401ks
wait 401ks are mutual funds no not
exactly let's start at the beginning a
[Music]
mutual fund is kind of like a bowl of
investments to thousands or even
millions of investors pool their money
to buy a variety of investments
primarily stocks bonds and currencies
which are blended together and then
divided amongst the participants and
just like a restaurant serves a lot of
different dishes mutual funds come in a
lot of different flavors some funds
focus on a specific sector of the
economy like technology retail or
agriculture others focus on specific
areas of the world emerging markets
refers to developing nations and some
focus on the size of the companies from
large cap to micro cap and they can get
a lot more customized than that the Paks
world global women's equality fund
invests in companies that advance the
cause of gender equality or for
something completely different the vise
fund focuses on tobacco alcohol gaming
and weapons companies mutual fund shares
are usually inexpensive and you get the
advantage of diversification without
having to buy hundreds or thousands of
shares yourself but there are costs
every mutual fund has an upkeep feat
called an annual expense ratio which
ranges from 0.1 to 2% of the value per
year some funds also charge an extra fee
called a load when you buy or sell your
shares
usually between 1% and 5.75 percent of
the sales price you can think of these
fees as payment to the chef who whipped
up your dinner wait who are these chefs
anyway and how are they deciding what
ingredients to use well that depends on
whether your mutual fund is actively or
passively managed active funds are
managed by a team of analysts and
traders they tried to outperform the
market by carefully watching economic
indicators and picking which investments
to hold and which to sell kind of like a
celebrity chef who's always improvising
and changing their recipes based on
what's trendy or in season as you can
imagine the fees on actively managed
funds tend to be higher
passive fund managers are more like
chefs who stick to the cookbook their
goal is to match benchmarks not beat
them for example an S&P 500 index fund
tries to mirror the modest but steady
growth seen in the index of 500 of the
biggest companies passive funds are
popular among investors who believe it's
a losing game to try and beat the market
because there's less analysis and fewer
trades passive funds are cheaper to own
mutual funds are an amazing creation
they allow ordinary people to invest
like huge institutions thousands of
holdings diversification while being
easy to use and letting you express your
personal tastes and principles but where
do you start if you don't have any
mutual fund investments yet you might
begin by opening an investment account
with a mutual fund company their
advisors will help you choose funds that
are a good fit for your situation
investors who want a more modern
approach are starting to use Robo
advisors to invest in mutual funds
basically you answer a few questions
online and the service automatically
constructs a personalized portfolio of
funds for you and handles all the trades
and holdings plus their investment
minimums are pretty low sometimes just a
hundred dollars and if you're invested
in a 401k plan through work you already
own mutual funds and you're paying fees
for an advisor so don't be afraid to
contact them and find out which funds
you own and what your options are I
remember the first time
I went to a sushi restaurant I didn't
recognize a lot of the ingredients on
the menu and I was a little intimidated
but it didn't take me long to learn what
I liked and I'm so glad I did like sushi
mutual funds may not be for everyone but
everyone should be planning for
retirement and mutual funds are popular
with investors of every level for a good
reason
and that's our two cents still wondering
about mutual funds well there's a lot
more to know so ask for some questions
in the comments below
[Music]